episode 13. the next day there are
multiple events going on so the
representatives split up to make
appearances at all of them
krusty attends an event with other
nights where sparring matches take place
he suggests that whoever is the
strongest amongst the knights be
rewarded with accompanying lenesia to
tonight's party
of course krusty is stronger than all of
the other npcs so he easily wins the
competition
lenasia gets pretty annoyed by krusty
but he seems to understand
the kind of person she is so they still
kind of get along over to the noobs who
keep losing fights and can't figure out
why
meanwhile michitaka is attending his
meeting where they discuss how the new
food is helping the peoples of the
land's markets flourish
the problem is that now there are more
goods needing to be transported but the
caravans keep getting attacked by
goblins
to circumvent these attacks they explain
that they're looking to start
transporting goods by sea
instead akatsuki reports back that the
people of the land seem to see the
adventures as potential enemies but they
don't mean any harm yet she also
mentions overhearing that the azumo
knights are missing as soon as she says
this their talk is interrupted by a
surge of magic
and a strange man named reagan appears
looking to talk with shiro
episode 14 is a bit of a long one so
i'll try and get through it fast
reagan identifies himself as the mage of
mural lake
chiro explains that his name had come up
a lot in town rumors and descriptions of
quests
they figured that this was all just
flavor text added by the devs and the
character didn't actually exist the two
of them continue on to discuss
different classes of magic there is the
action class
combat class operation class tactical
class
strategy class national defense class
continent class and finally world class
these are ordered by how much of an area
of effect they have
for example an action-class spell
affects the least amount without only
influencing one action like a swing of a
sword combat alters the course of a
single battle
operation class spells can affect
multiple battles at a time
tactical class spells are capable of
conquering an entire enemy castle with
just one hit
shiro points out that the game has never
had spells that powerful though but
anyways national defense affects the
outcome of a nation
continent class the outcome of the
entire continent bringing us finally to
world class which would be defined as a
spell capable of controlling the law's
fate or the very existence of an entire
world
reagan tells him that there's only one
world-class spell known right now and
it's been cast three times throughout
history this spell is called the world
fraction global enchantment and is also
responsible for the apocalypse if this
is the spell that caused the apocalypse
then shiro's first question is what
happened the first two times it was cast
well according to reagan 350 years ago
the world was far from prosperous
during that time humans elves dwarves
and elves lived together the alves were
magical inventors but that power was
their undoing
they were despised for their monopoly
over magical technology and since they
were such a small nation the other races
eradicated them this led to the six bent
princesses known as the luquenji being
born according to the tale the six of
them didn't know each other and weren't
working together they were all
out of women though and were pissed at
the destruction of their race and
culture
independently but also simultaneously
they all swore revenge
each took different routes to achieving
this revenge which plunged the entire
world into chaos
although their actions weren't enough
and all six of them were on the verge of
defeat leading to the first casting of
the world fraction
the technology and principles used in
the first casting still remain a mystery
but the casting led to the genesis of
the demi-humans in the world
reagan speculates that since there was
so much war it led to an abundance of
souls inhabiting the world
it's possible that these souls were what
was used to create the demi-humans
more war was waged against the demi
humans also leaving everything in a dark
age even though the lucuenji were
defeated it seems their dreams of
revenge had come to pass
to compete all the new demi-humans the
survivors used alf's secrets to create
new races and add allies to their
numbers
this led to all the cat people wolf
fangs fox tales and
robed ones joining the ranks against the
demi humans the event also coincided
with the creation of the precursors
precursors are the most powerful npcs
who are just
as strong as adventurers back in the
games lord they were referenced as
legendary heroes
they backburner the precursors for now
though to talk instead
about the souls which falls under
something called spirit theory
because souls were spurring on the
creation of the demi humans the more
demi humans they killed the more souls
they're worth floating around this
basically turns into the demi humans
reincarnating or from the game's
perspective
respawning jump ahead 60 years after the
first world fraction
and 240 years from the present at this
point all of humanity is on the verge of
defeat against the demi-humans
this led to a divine summoning spell
being used which was also the second
casting of the world fraction
it caused messengers of god to appear
which later became known as the
adventurers reagan wanted to talk to
shiro because he recognizes him as an
arc mage that appeared in their history
books 98 years ago
this makes shubert realize that five
minutes of playing time is equal to an
hour of game time
in other words one day in the game is
two real world hours
and if you did the math which i didn't
because [ __ ] that you find that 98 years
for them would be a little more than
eight years in the real world which is
when shiro had first started playing
elder tale
the time also lines up for the second
casting of the world fraction because
that's when the open beta was officially
launched
next they talk about the spirit which is
the mystical energy that animates both
humans and demi-humans the spirit is
divided into two segments the psyche and
the anima
psyche is the energy that animates the
mind as well as magic commonly referred
to
as mp anima on the other hand animates
the body and is known as
hp when somebody is defeated in battle
they can't move but the mind remains
healthy this leads to the anima
and the psyche being split the psyche
becomes trapped in darkness
because the information such as light
that flows through the mind to the body
is cut
off the next step is anima dispersal
resurrection magic is used on corpses in
this state taking the anima that has
been dispersed and reconstructing it the
downside is that the resurrection is
never perfect which leads to the loss of
experience points afterwards
while resurrection does work on people
of the land if they aren't resurrected
in time they perish for good on the
other hand for adventurers once the
anima dispersal is complete the body
decomposes into particles the psyche
then uses its power to transport the
adventurer to the cathedral
similar to what happens with demi humans
shiro explains that while playing the
game the
player is like the psyche and the
character is like the anima if the
character died it only meant losing some
experience points and since the psyche
couldn't be affected the player was fine
now that the psyche and the anima of the
players are united so are their memories
and experience
points thus bringing us to the
conclusion that dying in the game could
result in a loss of not only experience
points but actual memories because the
two are intertwined but even with this
realization it's not clear how much
repeated deaths would affect you it
could be something as simple as a little
forgetfulness or deja vu at times but
you also could forget about the real
world altogether shira and akatsuki
agree that it's probably best to keep
this information to themselves for now
anyways in the last couple of scenes me
nori finally builds up the courage to
tell the noobs why they're getting their
asses handed to them
episode 15. they decide they should get
more well-acquainted with each other and
their abilities once they get talking
everybody realizes how much they can
combo their moves together and
strategize their positioning
now that they have a coherent plan in
the fighting they are finally able to
clear out the skeletons
where you get a quick scene showing that
crusty is starting to grow on lenesia
later on we see that one of the girls in
the noobs group named isuzu has started
to get along well with rundle house they
will have to part ways once the training
is over so she decides she'll add him to
her friend list but we see that for some
unknown reason the system won't allow
her to
job ahead to the next day we're an army
of sahagine which are basically budget
murlocs attack the shoreline where the
camp is being held
episode 16. it's not just the sahagin
that are on the move but there is also
an
army of a few thousand goblins nearby
after reporting this to shiro an
emergency meeting is called by the round
table
during the meeting they estimate that
roughly ten thousand goblins are on the
move
shiro speculates that this could be
because of an event called the demon
king's return
twice a year a goblin king is crowned
and players are given a week to defeat
him before it happens
this was an easy way to get loot so
there's never been a time where the
goblin king was successfully crowned
although the admins did mention that if
the players ever failed then the goblin
tribes would unite and engage everybody
in a massive army when it was still a
game everybody recalls a powerful army
called the izumo knights
these knights were people of the land
but were stronger than the adventurers
and acted as the npc's trump card there
are said to be 13 bands of knights
around the world and whenever they get
into a fight it's to determine the fate
of the world because they can't confirm
that such an army exists they have to
figure out how to ensure the people of
the land aren't killed by the goblins
lenessia's dad stops by to give her the
bad news about the goblin army and also
to inform her that he's going to leave
to defend their hometown of maihama from
the invasion a smaller force is then
spotted by the training party and nyanta
speculates that they're moving to attack
the town of choshi for supplies
meanwhile shiro summons soju road to
help defend the palace of eternal ice if
it gets attacked with fighting on the
horizon shiro feels it's necessary to
tell everybody about the possible memory
loss upon death krusty had underwent
combat training with his guild when they
first arrived and died a couple of times
so he can confirm that afterwards there
were indeed memories missing it's hard
to know exactly which memories were lost
but he does know that the memories were
from the real world
a training party decided to go help
toshi but they come across a village
that had already fallen to the goblins
they reconvene with the other adventures
and decide that instead of defending the
town they will attack the goblins head
on
episode 17. people of the land are
trying to figure out how to handle the
situation without hell from the
adventurers that's going to be a little
bit tough though because apparently all
of the azumu knights have vanished from
the land and none of them know why
back over to the training group who
launched surprise attacks on the goblins
while nyanta and natsugu take higher
level members to fight the bulk of the
force
finally realizing that the people of the
land are going to need the help of the
adventurers in this matter everybody has
a conference
tensions rise when both sides are
withholding information and the people
of the land insinuate that the
adventurers are
obligated to help because they're so
strong shiro had assigned michitaka to
play the role of being against sending
adventurers he says that they can't just
be seen as guard dogs at the command of
the people of the land
it seems that the negotiations had
broken down until lancia makes her
entrance
she reveals the truth about the missing
izumo knights
and requests that krusty take her to
akihabara once there she wishes to raise
a volunteer force of adventurers to help
them
at this point she's kind of acting as a
bridge in the divide between the two
sides
she is requesting aid from the
adventurers but she's doing it in a
respectful way that gives them the
freedom to decline with that settled
krusty and lynessia head back to
akiobara while being accompanied by
shiro anakotsuki
episode 18. everyone arrives in
akihabara but krusty has to go handle
some guild stuff so lenesia gets stuck
with shiro we'll get her some new
clothes and sticker in front of the
adventurers in akihabara to convince
them to fight
she gives a rousing speech or whatever
plus she looks pretty hot in her new
outfit so she wins over the neckbeards
to stay ahead of the goblin forces they
use their prototype steamship called the
okopete
with krusty leading those forces
meanwhile shiro takes another force of
1200 adventurers to set up a strategic
headquarters in the midraw equestrian
park
back on over to michitaka who discusses
a divide that's forming between the
league and the corwin family
the people of the land think that
lenesia is trying to secure more power
for myhama
with the help of akihabara but they just
back burner that for now along with the
relations between them and the
adventurers until the goblins are dealt
with meanwhile the training group had
dealt with the first wave well enough
but there are still more coming and in
the last scene we see krusty's force
getting ready to engage the goblins
episode 19. krusty and his men go and
engage the main goblin force
we see that a system of communications
has been set up so that shiro can issue
orders to whoever he needs to
meanwhile the next wave is coming at the
training party but it's more than they
expected so they have to call shiro for
help
it commands the steamship okoped to go
help them we get a fight sequence where
the training squad shows off everything
that they learned in the dungeon
minori is acting as the strategist just
like shiro used to do when he was
playing the game
shiro was abnormally good at this though
being able to make insanely accurate
predictions as far as 30 seconds ahead
of time which they called full control
and counter the yoko pede is still an
hour out so they have to hold off the
saaging as well as stray goblins until
it arrives things seem to be going
relatively well
until a pack of direwolves show up with
even more goblins toya is getting
focused by too many enemies and none of
their healing can keep
up just before he's killed rundle house
jumps in to distract them so he doesn't
die
after he is fatally wounded in the fight
isuzu comes clean about her learning
that the reason he couldn't join her
friends list is because he's actually an
npc
it looks like he's a goner with none of
their spells being able to work so they
call shiro as one last ditch effort
episode 20. after hearing the bad news
shiro rushes to get to them on his
griffin yoko pede arrives to relieve the
forces on the beach while at the same
time shuro gets to the kids
shiro says that he's going to cast a new
spell but makes the kids swear that they
can't tell anybody about it he starts
out using a spell to redistribute all of
the party's mp
equally amongst the members next he uses
revival incense which brings rental
house back to life but it will only last
three minutes once he had to regain
consciousness shiro presents a contract
to him
this contract entails rundlehouse
becoming a part of log horizon
by doing this rundlehouse will be
granted the status of adventurer
similar to niante's cooking shiro had
formed the contract with the best paper
and ink in the game
that combined with him being a level 90
scribe allowed him to create a new kind
of magic
randle house signs a contract which
turns him into an official log horizon
adventurer and while all that's
happening krusty continues fighting
against the goblin forces where lenesia
is surprised to see a more vicious side
of him now we hop on over to the
cathedral where rundle house now
responds since he's an adventurer and is
greeted by isuzu
and a new game hud episode 21.
now we're gonna jump ahead one month
where we learned that the goblin king is
still at large but that's been
backburnered so that they can focus on
their relations with the people of the
land
the roundtable has signed basic trade
and peace treaties with the easel's
league of freedom cities giving them
their first ally
quests are also back on the table to
give adventurers incentive to keep the
goblins at bay
well out walking shiro overhears a woman
telling a story to a group of children
about how the adventurers had saved the
city
he thinks nothing of it until she starts
telling rundle house's story
and how he was changed into an
adventurer at the end of the story she
foreshadows that something happens to
the wizard who had converted him but
then leaves before he could say anything
to her
reagan and shiro meet again where reagan
tells him that he knows about the new
magic shiro had created
just recently reagan had noticed a
similar phenomenon happening in the west
meaning that another adventure had
figured out how to make new magic
as well minami is another one of the
major adventure cities to the west but
nobody has really heard what's been
going on there reagan also informs him
that there was an
event that happened in the west similar
to the demon king's return
called the demon festival of suzuki
apparently the uzumo knights were
involved in the event where you get a
short look at a party where lenesia
sends us into a flashback now that
there's an alliance
with the round table sergio wants to
send an ambassador to stay in akihabara
and lenesia seems like the best one for
the job during the party shiro nagatsuki
have a little moment or something where
they dance
the newly appointed ambassador lancia
goes back to akihabara with everybody
after that
to avoid panic the adventurers are told
about the loss of memory on death
through a rumor
instead of making some sort of grand
announcement now we jump ahead a bit
more where things have calmed down and
marielle wants to throw a festival to
celebrate autumn and they're going to
call it the scale festival
episode 22 is pretty filleresque so i'll
try and get through it fast
everybody is busy setting up for the big
festival shiro has been busy with
paperwork and learning so akatsuki takes
him out to blow off some steam you know
he drops in on them and it turns into a
bit of a rivalry with both of them
wanting to spend time with giro to keep
them happy he goes out with both of them
to a cake eating contest they end up
eating too much yadda yadda yadda later
that night him nikotsky end up talking
where minori comes across the two of
them and realizes that akatsuki is
crushing on shiro she's heartbroken but
she'll get over it plus she's in middle
school don't be weird and start shipping
it the writers are never gonna let it
happen go make fan fiction or whatever
it is you guys do and in the meantime
keep your history clear
love you stay safe episode 23. on the
second day of the festival we see that
the lack of [ __ ] amongst the
characters is starting to make sexual
tensions rise
marielle has been crushing on atsugu for
a while and henrietta for whatever
reason flipped the switch and now she
wants to [ __ ] shira also i just want to
point out that nizuku has been horny
this entire season and as soon as a big
titty guild leader likes him now he's
oblivious to it
[ __ ] off man but anyways we also get a
flashback of minori who had switched her
subclass to apprentice which allows her
to work under shiro as her teacher
with him as her teacher she'll level up
faster and learn his skills at an
accelerated rate later that night the
atmosphere is changing and the people of
the land seem to be getting more
confrontational
shiro deducts that something is off and
akihabara might be under attack
episode 24. after they look into the
altercations that have been happening
recently they find that it all started
within the last two days she rose
speculates that a group of npcs could be
trying to hurt the round table's
reputation
we then see a high-ranking lord from the
west named lord malves who shows up in
akihabara
shiro identifies him as a potential
threat because he believes that the
attacks on the round table's credibility
are likely coming from the west
he thinks that their endgame is to
interfere with the easel roundtable
treaties
if they succeed then eso can't
monopolize all of the benefits that
akihabara has to offer when he can't
come up with anything sojiro and his
groupies give him an idea on how to
handle the situation
over to lenesya who's throwing a banquet
to thank the adventurers for their help
against the goblin king
lord malves shows up and it's revealed
that his guards are adventurers from the
west he's a huge dick and starts
stirring things up saying that commoners
shouldn't be able to attend the same
events as nobles lunacia is trying her
best to appease the [ __ ] but
tensions are rapidly rising he then
accuses her of misplacing a letter he
had sent them requesting that they
prepare a warehouse for goods he was
transporting so they don't spoil
meanwhile shiro sends sojiro and his
girls on patrols to handle the
disturbances
i guess the logic is something along the
lines of it's hard to be mad when
there's a bunch of hot girls trying to
calm me down once shira hears that lord
malves is outlandish he is banquet he
decides to go pay them a visit
episode 25. shiro knows that lord of
males never set any letters so he
fabricates one with his scribe ability
leaving mal is confused
michitaka then steps in to offer up the
marine agency warehouses for them to use
instead
this forces mal's hand revealing that
there actually was no cargo he was just
trying to make lynessio look bad he
storms out and we see the festival
continuing into the night
minori has been noticing people talking
badly about shiro because he doesn't go
out much so people don't know what to
think of him she goes to talk with him
and wants to know if it bothers him that
he's perceived as some sort of villain
mastermind that's always up to something
he's well aware of it though and as a
[ __ ] care as long as his goals are
accomplished that's all that matters
later on while alone shiro is confronted
by dariella who is the woman that was
telling the rundlehouse story to the
kids
she appears to be an npc but really it's
just a disguise and shiro can see
through it instantly
she disables the disguise revealing her
true identity as naraya who is the guild
master of plant huiden but huyden is the
guild that oversees the western city of
minami so she's basically the leader of
the west apparently she had won the
favor of the nobles iminami
eventually using their wealth to buy the
cathedral similar to what shiro did with
the guildhall
after gaining enough authority over the
adventurers she ordered all of them to
join plant who yaden she had
come to akihabara to request that shiro
join her also
it's revealed that both parties have
been keeping a close eye on one another
she obviously knows about the magic that
he had created to save rondelhouse
well he knows that she's the one
responsible for restarting the transport
gates between cities but they're still
kind of unstable
not only that but malves was also
working for her and their little stunt
to undermine the round table
while talking she exposes that shiro has
been researching a way to get home
he can't prove that he's found a way
back yet only that he can make somebody
disappear
she points out that if he joins her then
he would have way more resources
available to him to accelerate his
research
the offer is rejected by shiro but this
just makes her want him even more
and that's all we get from that after
the credits we see that shuro and reagan
are up to something and plan on leaving
akihabara
i'm going to be doing the next season
and you can find that in the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the log horizon recaps in
the playlist on the right side you can
also find the links in the description
below and the only thing i hate more
than intros is outros